uh aussie host laughing at a spaceship
so that's
jeff bezos spaceship oh my voice cracked
wow nice yeah that thing is phallic
i mean it just it looks like a penis
yeah
so play it
rockets everywhere this morning well
outdoing his fellow billionaires in the
race to space
amazon boss this guy's losing it last
into orbit next month
[Music]
a rocket they call it blue origin
[Music]
does that look a little odd to you
will officially kick off the company's
based
reserve business yes that's right carl
good morning to you guys good morning to
allie that's right
[ __ ] the uh interesting shaped rocket
thanks for putting that on
australian people out of australian
people rule
yeah they just they just call it what it
is that's i mean that looks like a big
old dick that's a
space dick man it's literally a space
dick
i can't believe you unveiled that like
behold
the curtain drops everyone's like
that's a dick mate oh my god that's a
dick
it's basically it's the biggest
one right i think elon's is bigger
no it's not you hear someone paid 28
million dollars
to go up with them
isn't that crazy dude this is that what
is this tax
sham that they're doing with this
there's something really off about this
what is the point what is the point dude
this is like some austin powers [ __ ]
he's literally flying a dick into the
atmosphere not even like this high
though
he's gonna get he's gonna get to like
the shitty part of space yeah he's not
gonna be up with us
he's not up here no this is the cool
part it's crazy how the government
declassified us
yeah [ __ ] man [ __ ] honestly
i mean we didn't know we would be buying
candice in the future but
you know they basically declassified us
because like that was our [ __ ]
yeah now we have to like change our
plates yeah
because now everyone knows we're like a
round yeah
it's whack sorry anyway if you could see
our ship from the outside too
yeah it looks like a vagina actually
yeah it's crazy it's like
it's like the it's curvaceous
it's lipped it's just you know depends
a whap yeah yeah wet ass but
i mean it's still it's still round but
you know it's like there's definitely
labia yeah type
attachments to it
it's like a it's like a it's like a
labia on a dish
served labia yeah anyway yeah what is
the point of this
i think it's a tax write-off or
i like that conspiracy that he's gonna
fake his death oh yeah i like that
that would be pretty tight so then you
can manage amazon from the grave
yeah um and the dude that paid
28 million bucks to go up yeah is not in
on it
so jeff is like you sorry man you got to
be dead too yeah how crazy about the
family though is i got
you were the one that [ __ ] paid for
this stupid third dude
they get up one morning and the dude
wakes up late
and bezos is at the bottom of the ship
already like in some crazy ass suit he's
like oop
guy's like what sorry dude hits a button
and the [ __ ] just opens up he just
falls out and then it closes like
self-destruct
in 60 59 58
57. sorry bro
i wish i could explain but
honestly you're [ __ ] so stupid for
paying that money to come up here
epstein i'll be right down
he's yeah he's going to the secret
island with epstein yeah
and they're all going to be laughing at
their
billionaire uh dead income earnings yeah
but that's going to be a thing epson's
going to have like a shell company
that's still earning dollars in ten
years and it's like money's been being
deposited there
all while he's dead um you know that's a
good conspiracy amazon's gonna
be putting money in some weird account
that has spent
expenditures it sounds like some
queueing on [ __ ]
yeah well
here i am get illuminated dude get
illuminated dude
that's a joke speaking is a joke
speaking of culture man i watched
true detective season one oh my [ __ ]
do you even watch tv or cinema dude oh
my [ __ ]
dude do you even watch tv or cinema
now i can say i do after watching that
yeah finally a question
of season one in 2021 who even are you i
know dude
i know i'm a loser
clearly a little b dick loser i know but
it really is one of the best shows i've
ever seen my entire life
yeah it ends a little weird but
man the first like four episodes are
like some of the most
like i was captivated i've never like i
i can't remember the last time i didn't
want to like look at my phone while
watching tv
yeah and i didn't even i couldn't even
look i didn't want to pick it up you
know
i was so drawn in on this first time you
didn't want to interrupt the scene with
this is what it looks like when i eat
that
um but i i have a whole new respect for
matthew mcconaughey
after that after that yeah why did we
ever make fun of him
because we because that man could put on
the best performance i've ever seen
because we're b
dick loser i know we're tiny little
stinger dick
we want to be that guy that's why we
made fun of him
we hate that we aren't him every time i
have sex i die
yeah and we're actually dead right now
that's happened with sick
that's what happened with sigmund freud
they had bad sex with their little b
dicks
we'll end the episode pull up the
picture of us as sigmund freud
it's it's yeah sigmund freud sorry i
thought you said seek freedom roy and i
was like
sigmund freud
this was posted on our subreddit i
believe
that's us yeah
i kind of got my channel wrong the tiger
that spock
that's horrifying
i got my chin wrong just a little bit
should this be the new album art
over the podcast
it's so funny dude
[Laughter]
it's hilariously bad
kind of like it yeah yeah maybe we'll
consider
anyway guys uh vegas we have shows
all week let's get your sigmund and
freud tickets now
playing every single day at new york new
york hotel we have a new cat
its name is spock
oh by the way oh [ __ ] what oh [ __ ]
we forgot to wish everyone happy prime
day oh
[ __ ] not what's it what you know
we'll kick it off in the bonus with
happy prime day okay yeah what do people
see well is it still prime day today or
is it happy belated price it's kind of
it's
it's still prime prime day today yeah
okay but by the time this comes out
it'll be a happy belated for everyone
else yeah for everyone else but we can
wish each other a happy prime day we can
yeah we got a cake for broad day so
we're gonna be eating the cake
we're gonna eat that all right